Welcome back everyone is charlie this will be my
full video for the spider-man no way home more fun
edition like the extended edition of the movie
with a bunch of new footage there were 11 new
minutes so i'll explain what all the scenes were
there was like a completely alternate post-credits
scene that sort of recontextualizes the way that
spider-man's spell works kind of clarifying some
things along with a whole bunch of extra scenes of
like all three spider-man and new daredevil scenes
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos careful for spoilers from the movie
if you haven't seen it yet i'm pretty sure that
most people around the world most places have had
a chance to see at least one version of the movie
there were a billion deleted scenes so obviously
not every single one got added back in for this
extended edition i've done several deleted scenes
videos so i'll link them in the description below
so you can learn about some of the other deleted
scenes that didn't make it into this edition
so starting with the new stuff the first new scene
is right at the beginning of the movie before
the actual movie begins they added a special
introduction with all three spider-man andrew
garfield toby mcguire and tom holland introducing
the movie talking about how excited they were to
all come back and play their versions of
spider-man again like toby maguire andrew
garfield finally coming back continuing the story
of their characters how they all loved working
with each other toby mcguire and andrew garfield
have both talked extensively about wanting to
come back again but that might not happen until
avengers 6 secret wars they could always come
back in other projects too everybody wanting them
to make amazing spider-man 3 for andrew garfield
and spider-man 4 for toby maguire but then the
next actual new scene during the actual movie
is when peter and everyone get arrested by agent
cleary and damage control and get hauled in for
questioning so the new scene is actually when they
actually barge into aunt may's new apartment and
start questioning them before they haul them
to damage control they questioned peter about
the washington monument incident during the
events of spider-man homecoming when he saved
his classmates after one of the tinkers and
the vulture stolen chatauri artifacts explodes
and it ends with them slapping a photo down
demanding that peter tell them everything he knows
about the night monkey just more night monkey
jokes from spider-man far from home the funny
thing about the night monkey is that sony actually
released a special night monkey trailer when they
were promoting that movie after he'd come out the
whole joke about the actual night monkeys started
because of the black stell suit while they were in
europe and it was because of what ned leeds called
him during the big fight scene then betty brant
started calling him that too and that's how the
night monkey thing spread to the news and why
damage control knows about the name the night
monkey the next new scene is the deleted scene
of tom holland's real life brother harry holland
he sees him running off trying to steal someone's
purse and then hauls him up with his webbing you
see a version that's happening in the background
when he got the green paint thrown on him
after he holds his brother up with his webbing
the crowd around him starts yelling at him
saying he's too young to have been doing all these
adventures getting involved in the larger avengers
level stuff one of the women in the crowd keeps
calling peter 14 years old even though he's way
older than that during the events of this movie
he starts arguing with the crowd and it kind of
turns into another version of the argument with
the crowd that you saw at the beginning of the
movie when he's trying to save mj another angry
crowd member shouts at him saying that he and the
purse snatcher which he just caught are probably
in cahoots and his younger brother in the scene
harry holland says yes yes we've been in cahoots
the whole time so his younger brother did have an
actual line of dialogue in the movie but the line
is meant to be a meta reference to the fact that
harry holland his younger brother has been helping
tom holland in real life while he's been playing
spider-man since the events of captain america
civil war so they kind of have been in cahoots
this whole time just in real life the next new
scene is when they go back to school after the
arrest like after daredevil has saved them after
the scene where the teachers mr harrington get
all weird with him he goes to his next class and
the new scene starts with him in gym class and
it's coach wilson and the rest of the class egging
him on to show his powers by climbing the gym wall
all the kids in class are gossiping about him
saying things like he used to be my lab partner
and they start chanting climate climate talking
about the wall and once he does start climbing
coach wilson's sort of softly under his breath
hannibal burst's character says what a sick
bastard remember the whole idea during the movie
is that coach wilson was one of the people who
believed mysterio and thought the spider-man was a
criminal then peter runs down the hall past flash
thompson who's in the middle of a book signing for
the tell-all book about spider-man that he wrote
he tries to say hello to peter as if they really
are best friends because he had been lying up to
that point like yeah me and spider-man
have been best friends this whole time
and as he runs by flash thompson a bunch of the
girls swoon at him and one of them calls them
cute then probably one of the longest new scenes
that they added is this extended scene with betty
brant doing a news broadcast like they do it just
like they did during spider-man far from home
she's sitting in a very pink room on a big ornate
masterpiece theater style chair like it's this
very baroque looking type of news broadcast she's
doing where she's interviewing coach wilson mr
harrington and mr dell jb smoove's character as
well as flash thompson and ned leeds and then
eventually peter parker himself if the spider
that gave you your powers were here right now
what would you say would you say thanks or
thanks for nothing i would i would say thanks
for nothing there's a joke about coach wilson not
believing that justin timberlake was actually part
of nsync mr harrington starts saying all these sad
things about his ex-wife and going to deep dives
on reddit mr dell talks about how sexy he would
have been if he'd have been bitten by the spider
and become spider-man flash thompson keeps trying
to promote his tell-all book that he wrote taking
credit for the name spider-man like he claims
that he's the person who named him spider-man
betty brant grills him on other possible names
like arachno kid and the bitten she gets pissed
off with him because she's not featured in the
tell-all book when she's interviewing ned leeds
they have a bunch of jokes about their former
relationship during the events of spiderman far
from home about how he's been sending her all
these texts and it's super awkward between them
there's a fake commercial about a statue of
liberty design contest where one person has
dressed the statue as mysterio then the next
new scene is of him bringing ned leeds and mj
to the actual sanctum sanctorum they have a quick
montage of them setting up in the undercroft and
they play the monster mash song there's a bunch
of extra scenes of ned trying to rearrange a bunch
of weird stuff and probably like the big moment
during the scene is when they're picking through
all just the junk lying everywhere and they find
a miniature model it's like a perfect mini replica
of the sanctum like a mini doctor strange just
walking around all over this sanctum model and
they all just kind of look at each other like
wait what what the hell the next new scene is of
an extra broadcast of the daily bugle with j jonah
jameson they added a bunch of new footage of him
it's a quick montage of him yelling a bunch of
different things about spider-man one of the
biggest parts of this is j jonah jameson doing a
phone interview with an electric company employee
named walter burke who recounts to him what went
down at the power lines the events of spider-man
capturing electro during the movie jay jonah
jameson makes a big deal about how he's the super
credible witness who's telling him about what
spider-man did but then quickly regrets it after
the electric company employee starts talking about
all the other sinister six villains about how
spider-man fought a power man and a dirt man to
which jay jonah jameson doesn't believe like what
a man made of dirt a man made out of electricity
that's ridiculous then they have the new daredevil
matt murdock scene so later in the events of the
movie after the first daredevil scene like well
after it they pay off the joke about happy having
to hire a very good lawyer where happy hogan has
retained matt murdock as his actual lawyer and
they're in the middle of a deposition with damage
control it's this scene right here but instead of
paying attention happy keeps looking at his phone
which is sending him alerts because of his weird
security system and he watches as all the sinister
six villains are caught on camera getting into the
elevator coming into his apartment his phone keeps
giving off alerts and matt murdock keeps yelling
at him like happy you gotta stop looking at your
phone this is bad he also tells happy you have
to stop sweating it makes you look very guilty
to which happy says how do you do that like how
do you stop sweating the next new scene is like
an extended scene of all three spider-man on the
statue of liberty before the actual battle starts
they discuss how lucky they thank all
the sinister six villains are going to
be now that they're gonna get a second chance in
their lives because they're curing them peter 3
andrew garfield's character says that he's
loving this and says they should do it again
we should do this again you got it just sending
out the idea that they will return again
during avengers 6 secret wars possibly in some
other future project besides that because when
he says let's do this again he says next
time let's do it without all the potential
for us dying and then andrew garfield spider-man
talks to toby maguire spider-man saying i'll grab
your number after talking about how they'll
team up on their own separately from this
hopefully they'll pay that off sometime soon
too then they go into a slightly different joke
about the organic web shooters that toby maguire
has they asked if when he uses the organic web
shooters it's a clean release like if it leaves
a bunch of mess on him does he do it with his
mind does he just think webb and the web comes
out and then toby maguire spider-man says that
he can't explain it it's sort of like riding
a bike in andrew garfield spider-man says i
wanna see the holes talking about the holes in
his wrist where the webbing actually comes out
then probably one of the other biggest new scenes
is the completely alternate post-credits scene
so this post-credits scene is betty brandt on her
tv show at the school reminiscing about graduating
high school like it's at the very end of events
in the movie she says it seems like only yesterday
that we were starting an adventure called high
school and what an adventure it's been during her
broadcast they show another cringy kind of funny
montage of the events of spider-man homecoming
spider-man far from home some from the washington
monument some from their adventures in europe
with mysterio so like they go on all these crazy
adventures all the same stuff happened to them
but it's as if the spell has erased peter parker
from all these events remember the spell didn't
erase spider-man so like spider-man would still
appear in pictures if they took pictures of him
but if it's peter's actual face that's what's
disappeared and that's what they've forgotten
about which is why all the avengers characters
for instance remember spider-man fighting with him
during avengers infinity war and avengers end
game but like during doctor strange multiverse of
madness they treat it like they don't know that
peter parker is spider-man they just know that
there is a spider-man who has worked with them
in the past betty brant continues her broadcast
talking about the events of the blip avengers
infinity war ending the broadcast talking about
how they'll cherish all their memories showing
pictures of them also with peter parker erased
from all the photographs because of the spell
she ends the broadcast signing off saying happy
graduation go tigers which is also a bit of a
reference to the classic mary jane phrase go
get em tiger but really this post credit scene is
just meant to hammer home the idea of how exactly
the spell erases memory of him which is why he has
to get the ged because nobody remembers his school
records because they were taken as records for
peter parker himself if there's any other easter
eggs in these deleted scenes or any other scenes
in general that you spotted during the extended
edition that i didn't mention during the video
just write them below in the comments there's a
bunch of big stuff coming up my full house the
dragon episode 3 video will post sunday just
like normal make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss that everyone click
here for my video on that big house of the dragon
elizabeth olsen announcement and click here for my
house of the dragon episode 3 video i'll update
the link as soon as i post that episode 3 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!